this is my street on the Upper West Side
the day after sandy she can see there
wasn't much damage I actually come from
Wyoming and for me sandy felt like an
average windy Tuesday we never lost
power I've never lost Internet and that
made it seem all the more surreal
because we could see what was happening
around us the day after the storm I
actually ran down to the nature offices
on Canal Street which were in the dark
zone I picked up my bike and then rode
around downtown it was a strange
experience suddenly vehicle headlights
served a purpose you would bump into
people walking around with flashlights
an occasionally come across a restaurant
open for candlelight dinner
my reporting actually took me all over
the city this is the entrance of the new
South Ferry station at Battery Park
protected by little more than plywood
barriers the station was completely
destroyed even today the station looks
much like it did when I visited in early
December but the real shock came when I
visited places like Staten Island and
Queens where the neighborhoods were
devastated
for me sandy was a tail not just to
cities but of to storms the role of
modern building codes was also clear
newer homes often came away unscathed
whereas many older homes were destroyed
this is one of the new parks in downtown
Manhattan where the city has worked with
architects to design water fronts that
can accommodate occasional flooding by
all accounts these areas weathered the
storm quite well
this is USGS scientists BJ Reynolds
running a GPS device from the top of the
last sand dunes into the sea on Fire
Island which separates Long Island Sound
from the Atlantic Ocean agency
scientists have been monitoring the
barrier island for more than a decade
and for them sandy was a chance to see
how the island would respond to a major
storm their models suggested that this
particular location was susceptible to a
major storm surge sandy breached the
island entirely their latest results
suggest that much of the island is now
more susceptible to future storms
this is USGS scientists Cheryl hockey
standing beside what National Park
Service officials believed to be the
Bessie white the shipwreck has been
buried for more than 90 years but sandy
wiped out the first line of dunes
evidence by the strip of dark sand in
the background even in December many
homeowners in the area were already
fortifying their properties for the next
storm tangible evidence that a wholesale
retreat from the sea is not going to
happen anytime soon
you